[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Hi, there.
Heather, again.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hi, I'm Priyanka.
You've probably seen me on
GCP Live YouTube series.
I'm also a customer
engineer here at Google.
As a CE, I help companies
understand their big data.
Having access to big
data adds no value
unless there's a way to use it.
HEATHER CROSS: That's right.
Big data requires
a way to perform
big queries, which brings us to
the topic of today's episode,
Google BigQuery.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Today's data
is complex, and handling it
requires a massive investment
in system architecture
and hardware.
It doesn't end there, though.
You need strategies
for scalability.
Then, it needs to be
managed and maintained.
The result, a system
where queries can still
take minutes to hours to run.
HEATHER CROSS: But
what's more important,
developing the infrastructure
or finding insights
from your data?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, this is
where Google BigQuery comes in.
It's a fully-managed,
massive-scale, low-cost
enterprise data
warehouse, running
on top of Google's
proven compute, storage,
and networking infrastructure.
HEATHER CROSS: So by
replacing the typical hardware
setup for a traditional
data warehouse,
with the BigQuery
service, there's
no infrastructure to manage,
no database administrator,
and you can focus
on analyzing data
to find meaningful insights
using familiar SQL.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
BigQuery can serve
as a collective whole
for all analytical data
in your organization.
BigQuery is fantastic for
running ad hoc queries
and aggregating queries across
extremely large data sets.
HEATHER CROSS: And
it's really fast.
It can scan terabytes in seconds
and petabytes in minutes.
This makes interactive
self-service exploration
of massive data
sets viable, which
means better analysis,
more creativity,
and you can drive more
interesting insights
from your data.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: BigQuery does
not replace every enterprise
data stored, though.
For instance, it's not an online
transaction processing system.
And it's not geared
towards applying changes
as they happen.
Since BigQuery is a
self-contained, cloud-based
solution, it's also not
an on-premise solution.
HEATHER CROSS: Query
and storage resources
are allocated dynamically
based on your usage patterns.
Got a really big query?
BigQuery scales for you,
using the processing power
of Google's infrastructure.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Sharing
and collaboration are easy.
You can control access to
both the project and your data
based on your business
needs, such as giving others
the ability to view
or query your data.
And because you can use
standard SQL queries,
anyone can get involved.
HEATHER CROSS: Replicating data
across multiple geographies
ensures a 99.9% SLA.
You're always going to be
able to access your data.
And you won't lose your data.
BigQuery also encrypts all
data at rest and in-transit
by default.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
In terms of pricing,
BigQuery separates the concepts
of storage and compute.
This allows you to scale and
pay for each independently.
You can either choose a
pay-as-you-go model or a flat
rate monthly price.
HEATHER CROSS: Now, the
fun part, Qwik Labs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You
can check out the links
to start the Qwik
Labs yourself here.
These labs provide an
introductory walkthrough
of how to load and query
data using both BigQuery web
UI and the command line tool.
Keep in mind that these labs
will take about 30 minutes each
to complete.
HEATHER CROSS: At
this point in the lab,
we've loaded a custom data
set into the new table.
We're going to preview the table
and query the custom data set.
Locate the table in BigQuery.
Open the table and click
Preview to view the data.
Click Compose Query.
Query the babynames data set.
In this demo, the query
displays the top five boy
names for 2014.
Well, that's all the
time we have for today.
We hope you enjoyed this
episode on BigQuery.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: That's right.
Don't forget to keep visiting
our on-air webinar series, Quik
Labs, and our blogs.
All the links are below.
HEATHER CROSS: You can
learn more about BigQuery
through our Google Cloud
on-demand courses on Coursera.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll see you soon.
SPEAKER: In case
you missed it, be
sure to check out last
week's episode where we
discussed Google Cloud Storage.
You get to walk through a
QuikLab creating and managing
storage buckets.
Give it a shot.